Sammy who else is on the stage with you
introduce well because we're announcing
this tour we're going to do next year
where we're going to go deep into the
Van Halen catalog which normally when
Mike and I go out with the circle we
play fire six Van Halen songs play most
of my stuff a little chicken foot little
montos blah little Led Zepplin but now
we're going to reverse that and we'll
play five or six of my songs and we're
going to really go deep into the Van
Halen thing so if you're going to go
deep into the band Halen catalog you
need Joe Satriani otherwise you're going
to have some yeah there you go we have
Joe Satan in house yes it's good to see
you again now it's good to see you too
there's so much to talk about but Sammy
first of all your big announcement is
that you're going to go out and
essentially do a lot of the Van Halen
stuff that you and Michael normally
didn't do when you would go out Mike and
I we've been together now quite a you
know a long time and uh and we talk
about it all the time but we've always
kind of put it aside say ah you know but
it's just time nobody else is going to
do it you know if if Dave goes out you
know he can't sing my stuff it's like
you know we we can do a few of the early
Van Halen songs I got no problem with
that I did it when I was in Van Halen we
did a talk about love we did we even did
[__] jump I used to have bring
somebody out in the audience to do jump
but you know it's like this is really a
celebration of all that and we are the
only ones who could do it you know and
we're going to invite every musician in
every town you know first of all
whenever you play if there's a guitar
player in town no matter what city it is
they come out to see Joe just like they
used to for Eddie so we got other guitar
players will get them involved you know
other singers get them involved if Alex
Van Halen wants to jump out if David Lee
Roth wants to come out and join us come
on [__] you are welcome what are
the odds are there any odds that Alex
Van Halen would show up on your tour and
uh maybe join the celebration of his
brother or you guys not in I would hope
so no I'm not I I reach out to Al about
once a month for about 5 years now and
he doesn't get back to me so obviously
how do you reach out how would you write
or send an email I yeah I call I leave a
voice message I send a text and I send
an email the all three things Al give me
a call Al's favorite line to me was
always every time he wanted to get back
together he would say you know Sam we
ain't getting any younger so i' say hey
Al we ain't getting any younger give me
a call let me know you know what do you
want to do come on over let's get
together you know Mike and I'll meet you
somewhere what do we calling this band
Are We call we have a special name the
best the best of all world's tour it's a
Sammi Hagar it's my legacy tour Mike and
I our our quote is let's go finish what
we started see what I'm saying you can
see Sammy and the boys on best of all
world summer 2024 tour the boys are
going going to go home and sleep H and
they'll wake up in 3 days that'll be the
end of it
uh